This is Jacob Bernander and Askur Ingvaldsson
Educators, Guides, and resident Vikings from
the Viking Museum in Stockholm, Sweden.
Today they're joining us to break down
some of the world
weaponry and mythology of 2018 God of war.
Oh, so that's a proper Viking armor.
Big thanks to all at the Viking Museum
for joining us on this episode.
Make sure to go and check them out or the
links will be in the description below.
But without further ado,
it's over to the Vikings.
Oh, my bow.
No, you are not ready.
Stay back.
This axe looks like it's aerodynamic,
so perhaps he's using it as a throwing axe.
You haven’t played the game, Jacob?
I played a little bit,
but I haven't used the weapons.
I've just played the games.
When he is in Greece,
the blade looks like something mythology,
more like the actual Viking blades, the
handle is aerodynamic
That's why I think it's a throwing ax,
but it's quite big blade
so it looks like a mix.
So what we'd typically call
this is a bearded axe and Jacob's axe here
well a little smaller actually
looks very similar to Kratos’ axe
well, he's really swinging that axe.
Usually.
Well, that works.
You usually see slightly
smaller swings and usually you see them
fighting together with the shield as well,
rather than using the axe simply
one handed.
That's that's very practical
with the unfolding shield as well.
Yeah. Yeah.
When we reenact fighting,
it would be perfect to use something.
You can just pick up when you need it
because it's heavy to
run around with your shield all the time.
Takes up a lot less space in the car as well.
It does have a sense of balls
as well, protecting the hand,
which is very nice.
We do see too few shields
in historical and fantasy games.
We really need to see more of that.
That's a big plus.
he is throwing the ax like mjolnir.
It's totally rip off, though.
Yeah, it is.
But I like that
Ooo Draguers
I like them.
They're like Viking zombies.
But better if you ask me.
To me, Drauger is more dangerous.
They’re more walking for a person
with a mind.
This is more like zombies
attacking from everywhere.
From the Icelandic sagas
they're more like wise enemy.
You need to protect yourself
very carefully against, you know.
I like the idea that the armor
has grown together with them
Really sells the whole,
you know, all being buried in the ground
and having their old rusted equipment
with them as well.
But we don't see a lot of like
huge graves, actually.
So the belief in Draguer
or in the Old Norse conflict
that is possible stems from the idea
that the dead continue their lives
inside their graves
and in some cases you can even go
visit them in, you know, the afterlife,
if you will.
Somehow there's simultaneously
both either in Valhalla or Nifelheim.
And of course, if someone was restless
enough for want of vengeance,
they could leave their tomb and
wreak havoc
upon the living.
Well, you, me, I'm a greatest ambassador
to the gods, the giants,
and all the creatures of the nine realms.
I know every corner of these lines,
every language spoke and every war waged.
Every deal struck.
They call me Mama mia.
So we find Mimir.
He's like a giant, but
he's still a best friend of Odin,
so he's a special place in the mythology.
Odin's had me imprisoned here for
109 winters.
I like the
the image of the horns looks like gold
and with the Viking ornaments on them.
So it look like good drinking horns
put on the head of Mimir.
Kratos removes the head of Mimir
and carries it along, dispensing advice
and comments which is it's it's a fun
nod to me being the source of knowledge.
Just Mimir’s head, without
his body, is also mentioned in the sagas
because the Giants are not very happy
about this relationship
between Odin and Mimir.
Therefore they take his head off,
but Odin makes
the heads still survive and be living.
So therefore this is a good take
from that kind of perspective to work.
Yeah. I'm going to cut off your head now.
Fair enough.
Oh, so that's a proper Viking armor.
So we are dressed wrong, Askur.
I wouldn't say that.
First of all, loincloth pants
have been a thing in Northern Europe
for a very long time, but I presume it's
a nod to his Greek origins.
Leather armor.
People love leather armor.
The usefulness of it is very debatable.
But then again, if you're Kratos,
you probably don't need all that much
protection.
So oof the second though, where do I start
is sure the piece looks like
it comes from sort of medieval
armor, late medieval armor.
Well, I'm sure that anyone living in
the Viking age would have turned off.
It wouldn't have thought of the nose
to one of these people.
Drones.
It doesn't really fit your esthetic.
It does have some runes
written on something like
Hear my words in Gods or in Lord
to sire, to conceive the thoughts of
siring the rights right kingship.
The suit of armor does have some redeeming
qualities, including buckles,
not to one similar
to what I'm wearing here.
So you may have looked
at some Viking stuff at least
it's pretty well decorated actually.
Some of the decorations ripped straight
out of archeological context or history.
The problem is that it's vandal period.
Yeah, I'm not Viking period.
There's the plates on the belly as well.
If anything, it resembles Eastern east
Asian armor from way past the Viking age.
Possibly I'm samurai.
Don't quote me on that.
So the boy's outfit or age is a first off.
It has a similar problem
to craters, first outfits,
all of the leather and furs everywhere.
They do use leather and fur in clothing,
but it's very rarely,
almost never this raw and unpolished,
if you will.
Then again,
they have been living in hiding
and possibly
making hunting their own clothing.
So I guess it makes sense.
What is this
world
surface?
So the Midcard snake.
I like that one.
I like the monsters of the Norse
mythology.
German gander is perhaps the most
famous one is one of the sons of Loki.
German Gander.
He's like the world Snape.
He's so long and told that he can wrangle
around the world and bite his own tail.
Thor and German
Gander is not best friends.
They are the worst enemies of each other
and they will kill each other.
In Ragnarok, the end of time.
Yeah, they are destined to be the bane
of each other at the end of the world.
Why is he doing that?
Didn't have that
statue made in honor of Thor.
He's seen as the world's suffering.
Absolute nuclear force, the fat dauber.
He was probably sick of looking at it.
And it's also very fun thing
that the German gander is
attacking the statue of Thor.
So I guess they have learned
about their mythology.
It's a fun takes to have the serpent
talking rather than Iron Man.
This beast
is going
to get to being an offspring of Loki.
Some snark is to be expected.
Wait.
Probably
something's happening.
Well,
it looks like they are reading in ruins
and watching,
like, pictures on the stones.
On the top of this.
It's quite tricky to read,
but there's something
like E Hunting Face in Spain.
Had your boots,
which loosely translates to in the hands
of the one born by the Ain Hajar.
That's us,
presumably this refers to craters.
And Ain Harrier or lives there.
The Warriors of Valhalla, if you say so.
This time
showing the funeral pyre of leafy
ID Dana Kilmer, 30 until auctioned off
to tell you
two names in the main area in the death
comes Teddy I'm to at last back to George
and hame in the hands of the angel
30 until presumably
referring to a truce or a low.
As we know almost nothing.
Joltin hame is the place for the giants.
That's so much bigger,
Jim. Definitely the one.
A long way from home on you.
Oh, so we've got Boulder.
Nice. He's very special.
God, we've got sources of him, of course,
but I haven't seen him.
Like this is more like a poor
candle throw lower slave look. Yeah.
He doesn't even have a shirt.
It's altogether wrong hair color, but
leaving this painting for another time.
Balder means like the light God.
Or if you say so and some people
not are experts for some people
using him as a symbol of the Viking
Jesus because he's the light one.
And He's also interesting
because he is dying and that's all.
Luke is fault.
And he comes back after Ragnarok
to be the most important
God of the surviving gods.
No, he's very heavily tattooed.
Why kings? Did they use tattoos?
Well, we don't know for sure,
but we have some sources telling us
that Vikings could have on his chest
he had a tattoo written in runes.
Edgar Dowd.
I am dead on his back,
he said, bound in, like, bound on his neck
and it says it at sunset.
And it could mean I'm a sign of Ragnarok.
Oh, no.
I warned. You.
I know.
So Boulder and craters are fighting.
And in the saga, Sid Balder is described
as the very polite and beautiful
the God that everybody likes,
but he's not that likable.
So I understand
craters is why he's quite angry at him.
He's also used as target practice
by the gods,
amusing themselves
by throwing spears and shooting arrows,
which in the original story
leads to his death by an arrow missile.
Two possibly craters
could have a lot more luck in fighting him
if we were to learn this tale as well.
Can you make it?
Is it a weapon,
armor or likewise
an instrument of war of which I'm a master
at shaping the.
Dwarves in the Old Norse mythology of the.
That can be a bit hard to describe
now the names
I actually recognize them as Brock
and Ettrick and Patrick and Cindy are used
interchangeably and the famous affords you
a couple of things.
You know, which one is Jacob?
Yeah.
The most important weapons
and armor of the gods, of course.
And they are in a competition
with other dwarves,
and they need to make the best gifts
to the gods.
For example, you'll never.
Know the fortune seen.
It looks very high tech,
a lot more high tech than any Viking.
Just because the name is would have
had then again,
the dwarves and legendary craftsmen.
So even if they had an industrial sized
smelting oven, I wouldn't mind too much.
They also look a little bit like more
like Tolkien's dwarfs or from The Hobbit.
Tortured Beast is talks on post pathology.
Yeah, yeah.
Let me guess.
There's a Valkyrie in here. Yup.
Well, I'll be going to fight.
Yeah, there's a trapped spirit
in their quiet head.
So Oscar, it's
looks like they're fighting Valkyries.
For me, that's a strange thing,
because Valkyries is getting
the best for years to Valhalla
and to Freya and Falcon.
This doesn't look much like the Valkyries.
I've seen the all descriptions
of the flowing of the battlefield,
but primarily the scene is riding a horses
over the battlefield.
So if I were to give them wings,
I'd give them winged horses
rather than wings themselves.
But it's a very striking decoration
who I like.
I like the helmet that she has.
At first glance,
it might be seen as a horned helmet.
Those are actually two bird
headed terminals, possibly symbolizing
the two ravens who murdered off
Odin, their boss,
or employer.
So, Jacob, what do you think?
Well, I would like to play the game now.
I heard there's a new game coming up.
So I looking forwards that.
I actually bought the original game
for heading to work this morning.
So I'm looking forward to playing it
when I get home from this.
And I hope also crates it could be friends
at least one of the girls
because it would be fun to see that too.
Yeah.
Kiki believing.